D
IF YOU INTERFERE, YOU'RE GOING
TO REGRET IT.
>> Bret: PANEL, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
TODAY'S TRAGIC BOMBINGS BEING
DESCRIBED AS A COORDINATED
COMPLEX ATTACK.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN AT THE PENTAGON
WITH A LOOK AT THAT.
IF YOU'VE BEEN PUTTING OUT A LOT
OF HOURS AS YOU LOOK AT THE FLAG
AT HALF-STAFF AT THE WHITE HOUS.
FOR ALL THE SERVICE MEMBERS IN
THE 12 MARINES, ONE NAVY MEDIC
KILLED.
AMAZING TO WORK WITH YOU AND
TALKING TO ALL YOUR SOURCES, CAN
YOU EXPLAIN THE APPARENT
CATCH-22 REGARDING THE TALIBAN
AND RELYING ON IT TO PROTECT
U.S. TROOPS AT THE AIRPORT?
>> BRET, THE SICKENING FEELING
THAT I FEEL AND EXPERIENCED BY
EVERYBODY WALKING THE HALLS
TODAY, THEY KNEW IT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THEY KNEW, THE U.S. MILITARY NEW
THAT WHEN THEY WERE GIVEN A
STRICT TIMELINE TO PULLOUTS,
THAT THEY WOULD BE GOING BACK
IN.
THEY WOULD BE GOING BACK IN
POSSIBLY UNDER FIRE.
FOR 20 YEARS, THEY'VE TRIED TO
STOP EVERY SUICIDE BOMBER AND
EVERY TERROR GROUP IN THE
COUNTRY.
IF THEY COULDN'T DO IT.
THE NOTION NOW THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO HUNT DOWN ISIS AND THEY
ARE GOING TO STOP THOSE WHO
CARRIED OUT THE ATTACK BOGGLES
THE MIND.
THE PEOPLE THEY WOULD HAVE
RELIED ON TO DO THAT KIND OF
WORK, HUNT DOWN THE TERRORISTS,
THEY ARE NOW COWERING AND HIDING
IN BASEMENTS IN SAFE HOUSES
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET TO THE
AIRPORT FOR SAFETY.
ALL OUR PARTNERS SAY THEY'VE
EITHER LEFT THE COUNTRY OR IN
HIDING AND WE HAVE LEFT THEM.
IF THE TALIBAN HAVE LISTS OF
THEIR NAME GOING HOUSE TO HOUSE
LOOKING FOR THEM.
IF I DO NOT UNDERSTAND HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE OVER THE
HORIZON CAPABILITIES AND
INTELLIGENCE AND BE ABLE TO FIND
THE ISIS NETWORK THAT YOU CANNOT
FIND FOR THE LAST 20 YEARS IN
THE NEXT COMING DAYS BY TUESDAY
WHICH IS YOUR SELF-IMPOSED
DEADLINE.
THE MILITARY HAS BEEN GIVEN
IMPOSSIBLE DEADLINES FROM THE
GET-GO.
IT GOES BACK TO THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION AND IT WAS
DOUBLED DOWN BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WHEN
JOE BIDEN ANNOUNCED THAT THEY
HAD TO BE OUT BY ARBITRARILY
SEPTEMBER 11.
THEN WHAT IT SET IN MOTION AND
WHAT THE TALIBAN, THE FACT THEY
HAVE TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE
TALIBAN, LET'S REMEMBER WHO IS
IN CHARGE OF SECURITY FOR KABUL.
NOT JUST TALIBAN, IT IS THE
NETWORK.
THE HEAD OF SECURITY FOR THE
TALIBAN IN KABUL HAS A
$5 MILLION FBI REWARD ON HIS
HEAD BECAUSE HE'S PART OF THE
LEADING TERROR GROUP.
THE IMPOSSIBLE NUMBER OF
CATCH-22'S IN THE SITUATION THEY
FIND THEMSELVES IN IS BOGGLING
THE MIND.
>> Bret: YOU'RE RIGHT.
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS TALKING
AND HE SAYS WE ARE GOING TO GO
AFTER THOSE RESPONSIBLE.
THAT'S POSSIBLE, WE'VE GOT THE
BEST MILITARY IN THE WORLD AND
SPECIAL OPS CAN GO ANYWHERE THEY
WANT TO GO.
HOW WILL THEY GO AFTER ISIS AND
AL QAEDA IN AFGHANISTAN NOW?
AFTER AUGUST 31ST?
>> IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE.
THE INTELLIGENCE NETWORK IS JUST
A RIDE UP WHEN THE U.S. MILITARY
CLAUSE TO BAGRAM AIRBASE AND
THEY PULLED ALL THE CIA BASE IS
OUT.
THEY DON'T HAVE AN INTELLIGENCE
NETWORK ANYMORE BECAUSE ALL
THOSE PEOPLE WHO HELPED THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT ARE IN HIDING.
THEY MAY BE OF THE STRIKE AT
SOME EMPTY TRAINING CAMP
SOMEWHERE IN THE PROVINCE, BUT
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT
TO GO AFTER THESE GROUPS NOW
THAT U.S. MILITARY -- THE U.S.
MILITARY CAN'T EVEN LEAVE THE
AIRPORT RIGHT NOW, NO LESS GO
INTO CROWDED AREAS WHERE THE
ISIS CELLS ARE LIKELY OPERATING
IN HIDING.
ISIS IS NOW IN THE CAPITAL.
THIS IS A VERY DANGEROUS MISSION
AND MY HEART BREAKS FOR THE
MARINES AND THE PARATROOPERS WHO
ARE STANDING WATCH TONIGHT AT
THE KABUL AIRPORT